Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be
speaking with Elizabeth Coppock,
who's an assistant professor of linguistics
at Boston University, who specializes in
semantics, the study of meaning in human language.
It's really great having you on. I appreciate it.
Speaker 5: Thank you so much for inviting
me. I think this is a really important topic,
and I'm very pleased to be giving
my opinions about it. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So I mean, I guess just to kind of
set some context. Oftentimes, when people have
discussions that are very politically oriented,
like what is the Second Amendment really mean or
what are the the actual laws around deportation in
terms of what should or can be decided versus what
must be decided? Or, you know, we can think about
all of these different political implications.
There's often a split between the idea
of a textualist interpretation that is
just what's written versus one that considers when
such a statute or law might have been written or
kind of all of these different factors that lend
themselves more to interpretation. One aspect
of this is are we correctly understanding the
textualist interpret interpretation in terms of
the way that it is written and what that even
actually means? Can you talk a little bit about
the basis for asking that question and maybe some
examples of where the answer may be? We're not
understanding the language correctly, necessarily.
Speaker 5: Yeah, absolutely. So there's plenty
of discussion about whether we should be textual
lists or purpose of this or any other kind of IST,
but there's much less discussion about whether
lawyers and judges are actually competent
to carry out textualism. There's
this misconception that just because
you subscribe to the word of the day, you speak
English and you did well in fifth grade grammar,
you're qualified to make pronouncements about how
the English language works. But there's a whole
field of study called linguistics, whose findings
are applicable to these very, very consequential
decisions, and thousands of innocent people can
be summarily rounded up and put into federal
prison where slavery is legal, by the way.
All because of linguistic ignorance. So one.
Example of that is in this case, called Nielsen
V. Preamp Creep is for mo'ne pre-op. He was
born in a refugee camp. He is therefore stateless.
He can't be deported anywhere, but he's not a
citizen of the United States. And he served a jail
sentence for possession of marijuana, which ended
seven years before he was then rounded up by ice
and put into federal prison. Under this law that
says that the government shall take into custody
any alien quote unquote alien that's a non-citizen
who A, B, C or D, where these are
things that some criminal offense
they might have committed. When the alien is
released, what is released mean that means
they were released from the
custody that they were in before.
And so it says that the government shall take into
custody any alien who a through D when the alien
is released. Moni Preamp was released seven
years before he was later taken into custody.
And so the ACLU is defending him and saying he
wasn't taken into custody when he was released.
He was taken into custody seven years later. So
he should be released from federal prison now.
Speaker 1: And and so fundamentally,
this is about the words shall and when
is that really what this comes down to?
Speaker 5: Well, there are a number of
linguistic issues that arose. One is what
does when does it mean at the same time?
Or does it mean at the same time or as soon as
possible thereafter? And the the the government,
the Trump administration was arguing for an
interpretation that inserts or as soon as possible
thereafter. So it's putting a little meat on the
bones of the literal meaning. It's extending the
literal meaning a little bit. So it's a little bit
less textualist their interpretation. Ironically,
the government's position was supported by the
Supreme Court under the guise of textualism
because Neil Gorsuch tricked the ACLU lawyer,
who was defending pre-op into saying that her
interpretation relied on the idea that this
one clause, which is an adverbial clause,
modifies the noun alien. And so he got her to say
yes. Well, sometimes an adverb can modify a noun,
which is not true. And as a result? The Supreme
Court decision was against Manipuri up and
against the thousands of immigrants like him,
and so they will now have to all be rounded
up because an adverb cannot modify a noun.
Speaker 1: There's sometimes the feeling that
these types of questions and and we might call
them disagreements or differences of opinion
are basically just used in order to evade
what many would consider as just or having
to answer questions or whatever. You know,
one recent thing was when William Barr,
the former attorney general under Trump, was
questioned by Kamala Harris, who asked him whether
anyone suggested to him that he'd carry out a
certain investigation. The details don't really
matter. And he actually paused and said, What I'm
grappling with is the word suggest and really huge
political questions about, you know, possible
impropriety by the Justice Department. All
these different things come down to what does
he think the word suggests means versus what
did Kamala Harris mean? The word suggests means
at the time, et cetera. These things can. These
are really not trivial issues when they're
applied to such important things. Are they
Speaker 5: right? Yeah. And I think it's there's
this misconception that the textual lists
are always going to be the ones who are
the more conservative judges or decisions.
And we're all textual lists now, as justice, Kagan
says. And in this case that I was just discussing,
the text was actually on the side of the
people who are on the side of human rights,
on the side of people who are getting rounded
up and sent to prison unfairly. And as liberals,
we shouldn't be afraid of being textual lists and
of showing that the text really is on our side.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's interesting. When it comes
to them, when it comes to the Second Amendment,
you know, there's been a lot of
confusion about what the phrase
well-regulated militia means. There are some who
think about it as meaning regulation in the sense
of government regulation, the way we think of, you
know, OSHA and the Department of Transportation
and these types of things where whereas others say
that that's really not what it meant at the time,
and you have to understand the language of
the time period to really to really get that.
Can you talk a little bit about the change in
the English language over time and the role that
that plays in us when we try to figure out what
is even the textualist interpretation because
the language has changed over the last 200 years?
Speaker 5: But yeah, that's a great question, and.
I think that gets into matters of legal theory
that are a little bit above my pay grade.
Sure, I I mean, I'm qualified to talk about the
principles of semantics and pragmatics that are
applicable at any stage of a given language
and whether or not you decide you want to
take into consideration the context of the
time and and apply that to the whatever you
think the literal meaning of the words
was at that time. That's a matter for
you as a legal theorist to decide. Well, let
Speaker 1: me phrase it in a different way. If one
is making the claim that we should be going
by what was literally meant by those who wrote
something, we have to take into consideration
how language was used at the time it was
written. Do we not? Is that fair?
Speaker 5: I think that's a
decision that has to be made. Wow.
Speaker 1: So it made some might say,
now we're going to just go by
how what that would mean today.
Speaker 5: It is a bit absurd now that you
put it that way, right? So we have to decide,
is it the literal meaning of today or the literal
meaning of then? Yes, that it was written.
And I think reasonable reasonable arguments
could potentially be made on both sides.
But deciding what the literal meaning is is not
a trivial thing, it's not something you can just
say because you are a native speaker of
English. So there's this Scalia and Garner
tome on legal interpretation that is those big
white, male, authoritative text. And they just
state that in sentences of this form, only
this type of interpretation is possible with no
foundation. And then they appeal to very serious
sounding things like De Morgan's theorem, which
is actually a principle of propositional logic and
not a not a principle of natural language. And in
propositional logic, everything is disambiguate
it because you have little brackets in English,
you don't have that kind of disambiguation.
And so some of the ambiguity remains. And so
you have these these people who
are very importantly placed people
in very big, important positions,
making pronouncements with no actual
foundation and the consequences can be enormous.
Speaker 1: It was interesting recently watching
this Kyle Rittenhouse trial in Wisconsin,
where when it got into the jury instruction
portion where the jury was not in the room and
it was lawyers for each side kind of talking to
the judge about what is going to be the text of
the instructions that is given to the jurors.
There were lots of interesting moments where the
judge said my belief about what the the sort of
fundamental nature of this instruction is differs
from how it's written. And so I've modified it
for the instructions I will be giving the jury
based on, you know, I'm paraphrasing here what
he believed more accurately represented
the gist of what the jury is to decide.
It's interesting that in those situations, it's
a couple of lawyers, you know, arguing with the
judge, and it's no one is ever brought in who
specializes in language to opine as to what
is really meant by that. I mean, is that do we
see that in any different courts where they say,
let's actually talk to someone whose specialty is
linguistics to figure out what the intent here is?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I would love it if the ACLU
would hire a linguist, and I would love it if more
people trained in linguistics went into law.
And I would love it if more lawyers and judges
would talk to linguists about the issues that
they're discussing. Because while there, while
law is a specialty that you can't just
waltz into you just because you're a
linguist. Yes, the same is true on the
other side, and I wish there was more
talking between law lawyers and linguists.
Speaker 1: Can you give us one or two other
kind of interesting examples
as to how interpreting text had
major consequences that you've studied and whether
there are well-known cases or not? I mean, just
anything you think would be kind of interesting
and illustrative for the for the audience.
Speaker 5: Art. There is an example.
That Jill Anderson has written about, it
involves the American Disabilities Association,
the ADA. And. Actually, maybe I should
try I should use the Kariko example.
So there's a big, a big drug company. Novo
Nordisk and a smaller, generic drug company,
Kariko and Kariko wants to make this generic
drug available to a wide variety of people.
And the big drug company is preventing that, and
there's a law that says that the generic company
can make the the drug available if. The patent
does not cover any of the FDA approved use,
this does not cover one of the FDA approved uses,
and that is actually soberly ambiguous. So it is
not the case that it covers any of them, so it
covers none of them would be one interpretation
or there is an approved use that it doesn't cover.
That's another scope interpretation. So not as a
scholarly mobile operator. One is
a scope, highly mobile operator,
and these two supply mobile mobile operators
interact to create a scope ambiguity, not
something that is taught in fifth grade grammar.
Right, right. And there's an absurd interpretation
where it covers none of the approved uses,
and there's a reasonable interpretation where
there's one use it doesn't cover under
that circumstance. The generic companies
should have the right to make the drug
available for that use, right? Yes. And.
Just by Fiat, the people interpreting this law
said, well, whenever you have a negation and
something like one, it has to be interpreted like
none. That's just what I decided. And therefore,
we're going with the absurd interpretation. So the
recognition of scope ambiguity was nowhere in the
discussions about this law, and as a consequence,
people don't have access to affordable drugs.
Speaker 1: Right. So the sort of reasonable
interpretation would have been this is this is
written in a way where the generic manufacturer
really should be able to manufacture this drug
on the basis of their being one use and the one
that was applied ultimately was. This absurd
interpretation that led to the outcome of the
generic manufacturer. Just can't do it. Exactly
right. Wow. Yeah, that the number of instances
of things like that probably would be shocking
if we were to look in detail at at court cases.
We've been speaking with Elizabeth Coppock,
who's an assistant professor of linguistics at
Boston University, who specializes in semantics.
I really appreciate your time today and
you talking to us about these cases.
Speaker 5: Thank you very
much for the opportunity.